Sonia and faiza Ali you girls look so
much like Kim Kardashian and Kylie
Jenner it's almost scary and as a result
you've made quite the names for
yourselves on Instagram we love that
your sisters in real life too it just
makes the resemblance all the more
uncanny it's no wonder your insta count
has over 1 million followers
but enough about Instagram celebrity
look-alikes already today we're focusing
on celebrity doppelgangers who go the
extra mile on Tik Tok you won't believe
which riverdale actor has not one but
two real-life clones these girls look so
much alike they'll have you seeing
triple Kylie Stokes Kylie Stokes doesn't
need to wear tons of makeup to look like
her celebrity doppelganger if you
haven't noticed already Kylie looks just
like emma watson and there isn't a day
that goes by that Kylie's tik-tok
followers don't point out the
resemblance she's often asked if she's
that girl from Harry Potter and while
the short answer is no that's never
stopped Kylie from repping a Gryffindor
scarf the 17 year old look-alike has
over five hundred and thirty six
thousand followers on tik-tok page
Neiman while Kylie Stokes enjoys the
fact that she looks like emma watson
page Neiman takes things to a whole new
level
the young tick tock star has over 2.4
million followers on the platform and
she keeps them entertained by
impersonating ariana grande while Paige
does bear a striking resemblance to the
singer she tweaks her hair and makeup to
look like her even more but that's not
all Paige does on tick top she also acts
out tons of cat valentine scenes from
the show Victorious and she lip-synchs
to ariana songs too Selena Sharma and
then there's Selena Sharma a 17 year old
tic-tock user who has become popular for
looking like Camila Cabello on top of
looking like Camila Selena also sounds
like her Selena has over two hundred and
eighty six thousand Tik Tok followers
and she posts weekly videos of herself
dancing and singing while she doesn't
need to wear makeup to resemble her
celebrity doppelganger she looks like a
carbon copy of her when she does do you
think Selena and Camila look alike tell
us in the comments Kristen hancher tons
of women try to look like Kylie Jenner
that's just how influential the
self-made billionaire is
when it comes to Kristen Han sure she
doesn't have to try too hard
this tick-tock star changed her look so
often she gives the real Kylie a run for
her money
Kristen would fit right into the
kardashian-jenner clan her name even
starts with a K both Kristen and Kylie
are huge fans of colored hair and
glamorous makeup looks crazy vampy
Jordan just like Paige Nieman vampy
Jordan is famous for going the extra
mile to look like his celebrity twin
which is Johnny Depp if you hadn't
figured that one out yet vampy keeps
things interesting by impersonating the
actor and acting out some of his most
famous scenes while in costume he's got
over five hundred and forty eight
thousand followers on tick-tock so what
he's doing is definitely working well
some people think that vampy should
develop his own personality he seems to
be enjoying himself and there's nothing
wrong with that
Alyssa McKay Alyssa McKay looks so much
like dove Cameron she had to put a
disclaimer on her tik-tok page Alyssa
claims that no she's not dove Cameron
but we can't really blame people for
getting her mixed up with the former
Disney Channel star alyssa has similar
features to dub but what truly ties the
resemblance together is Alyssa's long
blonde hair and face shape alyssa has
over 1.4 million followers on tik-tok
and they constantly tell her that she
looks like dove Raven Billy Eilish is
one of the most famous stars in the
world right now and tons of girls think
they look like the fame singer but watch
out girls because claiming that you do
can put you in hot waters with dedicated
Billy eyelash fans but this isn't the
case for tick-tock user Raven who
doesn't need to go out of her way to
look like Billy nope she's a real-life
look-alike Olivia and Nicole Duffin
turns out there's two Ariana Grande
doppelgangers in this video just like
Paige Neiman Olivia and Nicole Duffin is
celebrated on tik-tok for bearing an
uncanny resemblance to the international
pop star but what sets Olivia apart from
other impersonators is her voice that's
right Olivia also sounds just like
ariana grande once you're done watching
this video tell us who you think looks
most like the singer Paige or Olivia
Jordan Johnson our spidey senses are
tingling and
we're picking up a Tom Holland
look-alike on our radar Jordan looks so
much like Tom that he bought his very
own spider-man suit to act out specific
scenes online according to Jordan people
tell him that he looks like Tom every
single day Jackie a Sri and cat Roly
Madelaine pitched is known for
portraying Cheryl blossom the dramatic
wild card on Riverdale but two of
Madeline's look-alikes hitched a ride to
stardom as the actor rose to fame Jackie
oshri and cat Rowley could be Madeline's
sisters they could even pass as triplets
here at the things we post daily videos
about all of your favorite topics so hit
that subscribe button and be sure to
click the bell to turn on post
notifications if you're watching on your
phone switch up your YouTube settings so
you never miss another video and that's
a wrap
which celebrity doppelganger would you
mistake for the real deal sound off in
the comments thank you for watching
don't forget to like this video and
subscribe to the things for more we'll
see you next time
[Music]